au cinéma c'est l'événement la sortie
mercredi prochain partout en europe
d'astérix aux jeux olympiques tenez vous
bien le film devait être projeté en
france dans une salle sur cinq c'est
énorme mais thomas langmann producteur
et co réalisateur espère ainsi
reconquérir le public son film est en
effet le plus cher de l'histoire du
cinéma français cher notamment en raison
de la pléiade de stars internationales
eric cornet jean christophe duclos les
airs de festival de cannes sur les
champs elysées c'était qu'il ya quinze
jours
effervescence médiatique savamment
orchestrée autour d'un film taillé pour
exploser le box-office budget record 6
mois tournage un stade entier
reconstitué au sud de l'espagne
huit mille figurants un millier de
costumes différents et surtout un
casting pharaonique gonflé pour
l'international sportif top model
monstres sacrés ou comique en vogue à la
limite de l'overdose
il fallait trouver des acteurs qui parle
à la fois aux grecs aux allemands aux
italiens aux sud américains en asie et
côté c'est pas l'argument phare du film
le fait qu'ils aient alain delon qu'est
gérard depardieu qui est des guest je ne
pense pas que ça fasse trop tactique
payante d'un point de vue financier en
tout cas 60 pays on peut acheter le film
apportant les deux tiers du budget mais
du coup c'est le scénario qui en
souffrent
ressemblant par moments à une succession
de numéros d'acteurs pour certains des
plus réjouissants j'ai décidé ce serait
moi ils représenteraient
aux jeux olympiques qui boit quoi nous
étions capables de te représenter trois
mêmes et que moi j'ai un tout petit dès
que j'ai une petite ambition césar de
l'ong brutus poelvoorde diot omniprésent
qui relègue astérix et obélix au rang de
figurant un choix validé par uderzo imam
c'est une chose qui m'a plu et parce que
d'abord il ya ce jeu entre brutus qui
comme on le sait est un personnage
historique où ces bons qui a en quelque
sorte été assassiné son père dans
l'histoire réelle
là ils essaient yade y arriver mais dit
tellement gauchement que il en est
ridicule et il joue son rôle à merveille
au final rien ne semble devoir résister
à ce troisième volet objectif 10
millions d'entrées de quoi redonner un
bon coup de fouet au cinéma français
c'est sûr qu'on fait pas d'omelette fait
pas donné